I think there are pretty much three
phases in one's life cycle in the first
phase you're dependent on others and
you're learning with your parents and so
on second phase is you're independent
and others are dependent on you and
you're trying to be successful in the
third phase of life there's a transition
to that third phase you don't want to be
more successful yourself the priorities
change but there's an instinctual
Behavior which is to pass along what you
have that's valuable I'm in therapy real
hardcore for the first time and what we
kind of came to recently so I'm 47 I
don't have any more career aspirations I
love this I'd love to keep doing it I
don't have a growth set much anymore
I've conquered the things I want to
conquer I have the kids I want I have
the wife I want and I think there's this
uneasiness for me for the last couple
years where I'm like What's Next because
I don't want to climb any more Mountains
what I slowly figured out and what the
therapist pointed out to me is like
increasingly I love being available to
to younger dudes I love it I'm sober
I've had a really twisty career there's
little opportunities I have to be of
value in dudes lives and I'm finding
more and more like I'm loving it in the
way I used to love touchdowns there you
go and I'm like oh I guess that's where
I'm heading and I need to embrace it and
stop holding on to the other version
that's right that's that habit the
obsession you kind of have to let go you
know meditate some more let go and then
what do you feel how do you feel you're
lucky to have the freedom it's wonderful
because you're free of obligations you
just make choices yeah so grateful for
it it's just a different well to get my
esteem out of and I really am excited
about it now that I can identify it and
recognize oh I love this this is
something that gives me great pleasure
and I'm endlessly available to anyone
who needs that and I like it you're not
taking time away from something else and
anyways it's funny you would say that
because I just had that kind of
realization recently